Guys for this video. I want to show you a cool trick
You could do with Safety Matches
now safety Matches are different than strike-anywhere matches because you cannot strike these anywhere they have to be struck on the red strip on the
side of the box
In order for them to light off whereas with strike-anywhere matches you can basically strike them on any rough surface
And they'll ignite
So what happens if you have lots of matches left over but your red striker strip powder is gone from Previous experiments
Or maybe it gets wet saturated or ripped off to the box. It's not gonna work at all. It's just all gummy.
There is still a way
You can light these matches
And I'm gonna to show you how to do it right now. Now even though these are not
strike-anywhere Matches if you find a surface
That's rough and long enough you might be able to build up enough friction to get them to light off like this
That's about as easy as it gets
now the key to making this work is putting your finger right under the head of the match then pressing it to the surface and
Dragging it in a nice long stroke if you do short strokes, there's not going to be enough friction for this to light off
But if you can drag it 8 to 10 inches you can see the light off no problem
this works because the friction [between] the match head and the wood is
enough to ignite the potassium chlorate just make sure you get your
Finger out of the way of the flame before it burns you
the reason this works is because this wood is very dry
It's very rough
And there's a long enough striking surface for the friction to build up where it can ignite
Now that may not always be the case if your
wood was damp or if you had a surface that was too smooth it wouldn't
Work the same, so you see this stick is moist
I actually dropped in the river and Matches will not light on it
But if we take a stick and rub it back and forth as if we were trying to start a fire by rubbing sticks together
The Friction will actually drive out the moisture and this has become a very good striking surface
I don't actually want to start a fire by rubbing sticks, but it is a very similar concept
By rubbing the two sticks together we've actually generated quite a bit of heat
Which is charred wood that means it's driven the moisture off and this is very warm right now. Now. That should be dry enough
We take a match
boom
and it lights
I got it lit off in less than an inch big difference, okay?
So it's been about five [minutes] since we rub the sticks together
This is already cooled down quite a bit, but surprisingly it still works really really well
The side of a Matchbox is red phosphorus, and when you strike potassium chlorate
it generates a chemical reaction what we're doing
Here is we're actually building enough to auto-ignite the testing cord itself
so you can see even if you find a moist piece of wood you can very easily drive off the moisture and
Strike your Matches how cool is that?
This almost works as well as the red striker strip paper does by itself
So there you have a [guys] using a few random sticks
You can find on a nature hike you can now turn safety matches in to strike anywhere
Thanks so much for joining me for this video, and I'll be looking for you in the next video. Talk to you then
[RANDOM HAPPENS]
[ENDCARD] Subscribe and like. Checkout more videos on thekingofrandom.com SUBTITLES BY NISHA HUSSAIN